all right oh no don't go outside wait no
hang on
hang on wait for it shut up i need to
cry hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to uh
at dead at night i know i said i was
going to do these faster and i
am i just had to get all the wharf stash
automated interview automaton out of the
way
and i was excited about that and also i
have a lot of things i need to do
okay so we need to go to floor number
two we gotta get there without being
attacked by the gymster
okay so i'm hearing the music that is
definitely an indication
that he is somewhere
that also is an indication that he's
somewhere
whoa hey bud
okay good uh that's
that's good is he gonna come back
why is the music picking up
okay so
i what was the uh dip d d for dip
e for dip okay so i don't hear that
okay but i think that means he's farther
down okay i just gotta get
to the staircase i'm gonna go for it
oh [ __ ] the music picking up wait what
okay i think it's left here oh god why
you [ __ ]
[Music]
what the hell man you skip
wake skip wake
where am i what did you do
god damn you [ __ ] the hell
that was what was i supposed to do
was it the musical cue
ah i always do this i always go to the
dead end area and i don't go to where i
need i don't know why craning my neck
i'm not going to be able to see around a
corner better
god damn you to hell
sorry i get uh
okay thankfully i'm right here so i can
just go get it right away
because the [ __ ] didn't exactly take
me anywhere far
more all right yeah okay so not much
progress
lost we can get right back into it i
need to go to the second floor
i didn't see what i'm supposed to do but
it's
for the other dude it might just be back
into knocking on the
door to talk to him because i got
something else or something i can't
remember what
i got the dickens scared out of me and
then i didn't have a chance
okay so let's just go to one two and
hopefully
it's basically just like a tax every
time i make a little bit of progress
he's gonna be there and beat my ass down
with a bat and that's just gonna be how
it goes
but hopefully i can avoid it a little
bit
at least i'm not actually dead meat okay
so somewhere this way
interesting
what was that what am i power up what do
i do
about that what do i do oh my god what
do i do
what is
what is that
[Applause]
what is happening
what was happening
[Music]
okay so there was definitely i think
it's just like something i gotta see
in the hallway there's definitely
something going on here
maybe i gotta like oh
you know i'm starting to think that all
the people in jimmy's life aren't
exactly the most stable
after all like jimmy you know he he did
pull the old oops oh god god what have i
done
he did pull the old this amount of hair
is getting very problematic
very difficult to deal with he's
he did pull the old glass in the
sandwich trick you know hilarious
we all know it's hilarious um you there
buddy
is it harvey harvey
overboard too distant try moving closer
okay he must have actually gone in
harvard the harvester
there it is okay saw you with a bat what
was that about
coming out of a room what have you done
that's my television
[Music]
i can't imagine why that didn't work
okay so well well i already know this
when you said jimmy seem retaliated does
that have something to do oh wait no
wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
no i know that was not it i know that
was not it okay so how could he have
retaliated
he didn't know anything about the broken
mirrors uh
let me go ahead and i'm just gonna go
ahead and scry because
it's quicker than doing all this
nonsense
that's fine that's normal that's normal
that's normal
that's a normal noise that happens
definitely
jimmy you're so funny and friendly fresh
hey yeah you don't exactly seem like the
kindest person ever
okay 210. aren't i in 210 am i in 210
is this 210 no i'm 2 2 3.
i need to be in 210 okay i didn't check
it's probably fine okay 210
okay interesting i don't
oh
everybody hide
you see nothing you see nothing
you see nothing every time
i still don't know how to get away from
him especially when he's just lurking
around a corner
maybe i should wait before making
movements you know he can't get me
unless i go to him right if he's lurking
around a corner
eventually he'd he he'd reveal himself
right
you know what i mean okay so if i dip
so i don't hear him okay so i'm gonna go
out and i'm gonna but i'm gonna
but i'm gonna wait and i'm gonna
save good god i don't know why it
doesn't really matter
he's far away okay that's how we know
that's how we know
it's fine okay it's okay
oh my god okay 218.
um very far away
i think it's on the other side that
sounded like it was from behind me
how would he have gotten behind me
oh [ __ ]
can i hide in the storeroom and the
storm storm
safe in the storm very safe i don't have
keys
ah crap i don't have keys i've got no
keys
no keys anymore
oh god no wait no hang on
no it's not fair hey oh god damn it
he's a tough cracker you know he's a
tough son of a [ __ ]
tough son of a [ __ ] tough son of a
[ __ ]
okay i'm still on level two hey
yeah yeah fine yeah i know
first floor store i know
i oh god every time
every time not that way no way
oh there's no other way every time
i'm just going for it screw all of
everything
all right i am just god damn terrible at
this game
for some reason where am i where
is it what where am i
help hey hey now where is it
where is it where the hell am i
give me a map the hell where wow
where am i oh
my god
fine that's fine i'm also really hoping
that my game isn't just completely
broken
in that i don't have any keys anymore
for some reason
because that would be really frustrating
but i imagine if there's
there's a need for keys
[Music]
oh i'm gonna figure out a way to get
them because i found those keys last
time which are still not here
whatever it's fine okay so i need to go
get this get back up go to 210
and then avoid him just
just avoid him just just avoid him
that's all i got to do
i just got to avoid him because the
thing is
like i don't think he can charge down a
hallway at me
i really don't think he can
and if he can't do that then i like i
shouldn't have to panic
is the thing i i shouldn't have to panic
because i should be able to run away and
hide somewhere but the only thing is
i don't have keys so i can't i can't do
the whole lockbox thing or the deadbolt
thing
okay which way was 210
201 maybe not oh no
it's probably like at the very end of no
no
no no way
no way what was this number no
number on that what's this number 206
yeah it's got to be down this way
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely oh yeah
oh yeah here it is no here it is perfect
okay what am i looking for in here
what do we got hello hi
oh that's a crush
that's a crossbar did he
shoot you with a crossbar
is that what he did
did he shoot you with a crossbar
[Music]
my god if he shot him with a crossbar
that's that's hardcore
that's that's some retaliation i didn't
think you were going for the medieval
warfare definition of retaliation but
oh yeah yeah crossbow i know about the
crossbar is that a crossbow or a tripod
or a telescope no crossbar i saw the
arrow flying
or the oh flying as they call it
okay is he there i don't care i'm going
i'm going for it i ain't afraid of you
[ __ ]
nothing there ain't nothing okay so i'm
gonna go ask him about the crossbar
there's no one here freaking
empty in here bro
oh
freaking empty in here bro you ain't
here
oh god he's here oh god he's here
i'm running away as fast as i can
oh my god i'm going in here
i'm doomed aren't i oh [ __ ] hims
oh dickhams oh dick my ikkums
he'll never know he will literally
never know he he can
never know
ah he doesn't know this is the thing he
doesn't know
he doesn't know what he doesn't know
won't hurt me
oh
so he sounded pretty far away so i'm
assuming that he wasn't coming over here
so it should be okay to at least check
the uh
the spyglass oh definitely hear him
he's going to skate right by and then
i'm going to go the other way
almost too easy almost too easy
mr whatever your last name is i only
know you by jimmy
there he goes yeah you better get out of
here you
better run [ __ ] you better run [ __ ]
you better run
you better run [ __ ] the hell was that
i don't like any of this i don't trust
any of it
what are you doing what the hell you
doing
shut up yeah fade music
get out here music [ __ ] i need to stop
saying [ __ ] so much
okay either way i'm gonna go left i'm
gonna go left
no cause it's a dead end over there god
i have to go this way
i'm going
i'm going
[ __ ] you can't kill me
you'll never take me alive
oh here we go again god i'll never get
out i should've just taken the levator
i should have just taken the levator i
should have just taken the levator okay
you know what i'm just gonna go straight
in the bathroom i don't know if the
bathroom's a better place to be
it probably ain't there's a thing about
it
i'm never going to get out of here i'm
literally never going to get out here
i just want to get the 2 2 3. it would
have been better just to die
it's kind of better just to die
i don't want to die i don't want to die
don't kill me jimmy he's not coming in
here if you if he was chasing after me
that closely he would barge down the
door already i'm good
i'm good to go i'm not gonna [ __ ] foot
around about this i don't have time to
pussyfoot
i ain't gonna pussyfoot i'm gonna
penis foot i'm gonna penis foot my
pussyfoot's a strange is that like how
cats walk i don't understand
is that to the right i think that was to
the right
i think that was to the right okay so i
think i can go left
i think i get out of here i think i'm
going to make it i think i'm going to
make it i say with complete confidence
100 confidence i am dead i'm not going
in that room i
thought it was the other way god damn
you
[ __ ] my child was just looking at the
spy glass if he if he pops in he's going
to kill me anyway so it don't
freaking matter go by i wasn't in here
what are you talking about
what are you talking about yeah how were
you there
how were you to the right how were you
to the right
someone want to explain how that worked
you're over there then you were over
there
and that's dead end
this son of a [ __ ] this son of a [ __ ]
i swear to god
maybe i need to like call him you know
what i mean
that's probably the tactic right
ooh that's probably the tactic
i'm gonna do that okay i'm gonna call
him and i'm gonna watch him walk on by
oh i'm here all right hey
hey okay
watch this he's gonna walk on by i'm
gonna go right out the door
or he's literally not gonna do anything
i swear jimmy i swear
jimmy i swear
i swear jimmy
i'm going i'm going for it i'm going to
[ __ ] you jimmy [ __ ] you i'm going for it
ah here i go i'm ready ready for my life
not that way [ __ ] ah
no god i forgot that's a dead end over
there i was gonna make it
i was gonna make it i didn't
i i i my sense of direction
really isn't serving me very well in my
time of need which is now
oh piss piss piss off whispers of the
damned whatever am i
oh i'm on the third floor oh
oh god i'm i i i have no apologies that
i will make because i refuse to
apologize for
someone else being a douchebag to me
i will not apologize i should have just
gone ahead and
died the first time and
it would have been fine but no i had to
try
that was my problem i tried and every
time i try
everything goes to crap
all right my tantrum is now over you
squeak
shut up
i've gone into i've taken two steps two
steps forward i've taken two steps
forward i found a crossbar
don't look at the table don't you dare
look at the table
okay but i think i i would have been
fine there if i hadn't
turned around is what i'm realizing i
would have been fine
all right i gotta go to two two three
and if i can get to two two three i can
talk to this dude
and then he can tell me exactly what it
is
that i'm gonna need to do ah
yeah of course it's at the very end i
would have been able to sprint all the
way through it i know i would have
i know i would have it's not here is it
no it's not here he's not here is he
probably is is it this way
219 maybe oh god wait
no he's not here is he
i swear if he hits me one more goddamn
time
he's not here there's no way there is no
way why would he be haunting this floor
still idiot
here we go finally harvey
my main man the big squeeze
harvey harvey
yeah is it harvey is it harvey
[Music]
did he retaliate with the crossbar when
you said jimmy soon retaliated
does that have anything to do with what
you said about the crossbow
did he kill you with a crossbar
i hadn't seen him all night
[Music]
you say little trick oh
yes i'm on the tool oh my goodness
that doesn't seem like such a little
trick a crossbow bolt to the gut
uh probably not great if
i had to guess not great no don't move
into the room don't you dare move into
that room
don't you dare scry scry
okay so now that we got big
gym energy up in here
i think we just need to play hopscotch
with the rooms
and then when he goes the other way you
just sprint as fast as you can
215 great okay 2 15. i am expecting a
crossbow bolt to the gut
in 215 but maybe i could set it up so
that i could just
kill jimmy right now that'd be great
i'm leaving i'm going now i'm not even
gonna wait
jimmy are you there
okay i think that's a scripted thing
it's definitely a scripted thing jimmy's
not here i would have heard him shouting
by now
okay 215 okay it's this way
okay oh
my god
i hate that
oh i hate that oh it's awful
oh that's awful i hate it
oh boy
well i'm wrong every time well this
seems like a bad idea
i probably shouldn't go into the room
that i foresaw with a crossbow
here we go oh i'm fine
thought i would be dead i thought that
was it
i thought death would have come
apparently
not oh
oh great i found that good okay
don't come find me don't
find me oh lag
[Applause]
okay so it's just it was one of those
baby crossbows you know for kids
toddler's first crossbow
how are you there is it harvey
harvey
yeah ah
so about you being shot with a crisper i
saw you being shot in the leg with an
arrow
it's a bolt actually it's a bolt when i
open the
[Music]
d get door and tetanus shots when i go
back
i couldn't find him rose said he was
hiding in the basement
that gave me an idea ah an idea i love
it when you have ideas i
love it when you have ideas i love when
you have ideas
however was the idea involving
roping an elevator because that idea has
already been tried
i'm guessing i need to go down the
basement but you know i'm just doing
this so i don't waste any time
because god knows jimmy's gonna come
stab me in the ass
but to see she 201 i would not have
known
i would not have known 201 holy [ __ ]
yes yes yes what
oh what the hell
okay the wind whistling in my ear
doesn't help me hear jimmy's approach
jimmy are you there
[Music]
that sounds really close jimmy if he
goes right i go left
and then i don't turn around like an
idiot
come on jimmy come on come on you know
what you want to go to the right
you know you wanna go to the right come
on jimmy
come on come on jimmy
come on
god damn you jimmy what happens if i
call him here is he gonna
wha wha where where okay oh
interesting interesting
okay is he gonna come right to this room
though that's the big question probably
not right
hello there he
ah so he go right by
he go right by
and now i i'm free to leave and run
i'm going this is so easy watch
this expert maneuvering
expert maneuvering i know exactly where
i'm going
and i'm going exactly oh [ __ ]
what the hell how did i do that
god god look
second floor makes no sense to me second
floor makes
not a single bit of sense doesn't make
okay
that was weird i'll admit that was a
little weird
how am i going to get a i can i i just i
i can't
i have a really good ability to create
mental maps
that is my thing i if i go somewhere
with gps once i can get
back and there again like without even
looking at a map again i can do that i'm
good at the navigation thing
this floor throws my entire brain off
and i don't know why
okay so i guess i just gotta go for it
you know i guess i just go for it you
know
i don't go for things i i just go for it
give me you there i'm gonna move up
one and then maybe pop in here
and then call out to him that he walks
right by
and then i get this stink wink
whatever okay i'm gonna call out to him
which i guess involves opening the door
which i did not know
down here down here
downhill come here
jimmy jim sir
jimbo the jimothy
oh oh no
don't kill me just go
safely to the left okay is he not even
gonna show up
i swear i swear if this guy gives me
more
lip
was he he was like all the way on the
other side of the floor wasn't he
i know that's why i called to you
okay this time i'm going
whenever he takes his sweet goddamn time
there he is okay about time okay he's
gonna go left
and then i go now here we go baby
we got this easy peasy easy and then i
run
away and i run it very fast and i go the
correct direction
the correct direction this is the
correct direction no this is not the cry
ah how do i keep doing this
i swear it would just be easier for me
to
die if i just died
everything would be fine
clearly
i'm just gonna go he's gonna go i'm just
gonna go if he hits me he hits me
if he hits me he hits me it's a shortcut
there's no more what there's no more
what eat a dick
you're a dick
what this where what but
i needed to go 201 right [ __ ] i'm dead
i needed to go 201 what is this 201
[Music]
oh god oh what did i get i don't know
help
go in the closet in the closet
i got a gun you [ __ ]
[ __ ] off jimmy i have a gun i have you
got boobie
you come in here you get gunned
i'm i'm playing okay whatever he doesn't
know i'm in here
he keeps saying he knows i'm there but
not he don't know i'm here
is the thing he actually don't know for
surely
[Music]
and he also don't know i have gun now
i'm going to shoot you jimmy
peace what
oh yeah i got keys that was less
important though i was more
concerned about the gun what did what do
the keys mean
yeah i probably just got to go talk to
uh harvey again wherever the hell he was
where
was he it's like 213 or something like
that
i don't know what did i find rusty keys
uh i don't remember well i the compass
will tell me
the compass should tell me
okay i don't hear anything oh
bro that was left rumbling left
okay music's kicking up
okay my gamer instincts are flaring
okay so
okay
i don't know where i need to go i'm
leaving
i'm leaving
can't hide in rooms forever okay so
okay so that's saying i need to go
you can't see me
maybe you can see me
i don't hear him
am i supposed to be like this able to
see his shadow or something
i'm going
oh god no
i'm just gonna do the shouting trick
i'll just call for him
unless he's already on the way because
that definitely sounded like right
around
oh my god oh my god
i'm dead anyway just god damn it
[Music]
you're gonna kill me i know you are just
get it over with
okay
i'm just making sure that it's not like
a double fake out or something i would
not put it past this game
i would not put it past this game
absolutely not put it passes again
i could not i can't tell where it's
coming from
i can't i think i just got to do the
call out
this way yeah this way
i was in that room you just checked in
idiot
fool oh my god
i swear it would be easier just to run
for it all the strategizing is only
causing me pain and suffering
pain and suffering
hurry up
well that is like so nearby where is he
clearly you don't clearly you don't
okay come on come on
there why that i need to go left
how were oh you were to the right i
could have just
gone oh
i'm gonna call him again he's gonna he's
go he's gonna come this way
jimmy we're right here [ __ ] jimmy
yeah me yeah don't come in here i swear
to god i will
i will gun you yay okay
that was aggressive and quick i like the
sound of that
okay i'm going i'm going i'm going i'm
not wasting i'm not not wasting
don't have time to waste i'm just going
for it i know it was this way
and i know i'm not turning around there
god damn it
this way this way this way
this way this way this way
this way nailed it i'm a genius i'm a
genius
someone there maybe i shouldn't talk
hello
gun gun quick gun quick quick about the
gun
gun go oh is it javi
all right harvey hurry harvey yeah
harvey got a gun belong to you gun your
gun
[Music]
just old bullets in it loaded not very
safe what are those rusty old keys for
that
does that have something to do with
those rusty keys
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh okay yeah yeah i go lower i look i go
lower
all right now i just gotta get out of
here right
what what was that
oh jimothy here i am
hey now let's see if i can get the hell
out of here correctly
the first time that would be lovely it
would be
so lovely if i could do that
be so lovely if i could
just figure out how to get out of here
correctly
i would be so happy i would be
so happy and yet i don't feel very
happy
there he is hey buddy hey buddy
all right and then we
run for it perfectly executed
no flaws here and then we're going and
then the correct direction is this way
definitely 100 guaranteed
this is the direct yes i did it oh my
god i did it guys
holy [ __ ] i did it i did it
i learned my brain god jimmy you would
get
lost in the wrinkles of my brain
ah it's like a grand canyon up in my
skull
ah anyway sorry
uh what happened in the basement and how
did it link to uh
good old harvey dying
hello hey
hey hello
ah oh
spooky
seems like jim might have some emotional
scarring
but uh kind of also a dick so
you know who's there anybody there
no you're not here ah dang it
do i gotta go back up really
i gotta go back up oh
you oh you all right fine
but i'm not gonna go all the way up i'm
gonna scry first
actually no it's probably two let me
just pop out on two if my compass starts
going wibbly woo then i know it's on two
that's the rule wibbly woo means two
okay finally thank you okay
compass do i have a compass i don't have
a compass
no it's not here interesting interesting
interesting good thing i wasn't here
because i didn't want to be there i'm
going to go to the ground floor
because i'm going to go to the i'm going
to the kitchen so that i can scry
and then i can figure out where i need
to go without wasting too much time
okay okay okay okay the time for
frustration has passed announced to
smooth sailing from here on out
minus all of the dead people and minus
all of my friends being kidnapped
smooth sailing there is no issue here
all is good hello
quicker on the information train would
be great
a little bit more expedient would be
what why what what
what is what 2 2 12
2 the compass no spun how was i supposed
to know it's going to be 2 12
i was just hmm all right
that's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay so the answer is just
when when it doesn't give me the next
step i just automatically scry
i auto scry i scry and that's it
i just cry and that's the end of it scry
and say goodbye that's the other rule
try and goodbye i swear if jimmy just
beans me in the head i'm ending the
episode immediately
okay which way is 212 212 is this way
jimmy are you there
i'm trusting
the hell oh
he's behind me oh no no no no go go
god damn it uh uh uh
this way
oh that's good
that sounds okay smoke coming out of the
hotel that's good
that that's that's good
that's a plus
didn't i already have stairs level three
or no i didn't have
that's great okay so he's not coming in
here definitely
okay so let me scry when scry and say
goodbye it's crying goodbye
then we know where we're gonna go
uh we don't waste any time yeah i get
harvey i need to talk to you but
why i need to go on the merry-go-round
of everywhere
yeah i know the photos i know about the
photos i am aware of
the photos i'm aware
okay i'll go down
[Music]
okay whatever it's fine
okay i'm gonna just call to him
i'm gonna take a right and a right and
get to the elevator
and i'm oh [ __ ] oh god down here
oh god oh god oh god no
oh no oh
oh god damn it i didn't mean to call
twice i didn't mean to
oh he's definitely gonna get me now
ah
oh he's gonna get me
[Music]
oh
oh
oh so the question is where did he go
afterwards
where did he go
so he's close i knew he was gonna be
close
i knew it i knew he was going to be
close so he might actually pass by the
door
and if he goes to the left i'm good but
if he comes from the left i'm scrud
come on move you [ __ ] move move
oh what the heck and what what why
why would he come back i'll just do
nothing
i did nothing to you i did
nothing
i did literally nothing
you were just waiting for me to come out
of the room you were waiting for me
he's gonna get me now he's gonna get me
this
i will end the episode immediately only
in the episode
i don't trust any of that
if i swear if he comes back again i'm
just gonna let him i'm just gonna wait
for him to open the door
i'm literally gonna look him in the eye
as he beans me in the face
because it would be quicker than this
okay i'm going i'm just going i'm gonna
go for it
oh god which way do i need to go
i forgot i think to the right definitely
to the right
no you can't shut up
hey buddy god damn it
this guy is making it very difficult to
stay alive
i just want to get by just let me
buy don't pop in this room just walk on
by and i will say goodbye
and uh you know what i'm gonna you're
gonna i'm gonna look at you i'm not
gonna do anything i'm not gonna do [ __ ]
i ain't gonna do i'm gonna go to the
closet i'm gonna go wardrobe this time
wardrobe time for me please
wardrobe i want to be caught in the
wardrobe what
the hell
what
what what what
what
why is it red red
red oh god that's
what you did you [ __ ]
oh you [ __ ] you [ __ ] goddamn
all right hey well that's great i'm
ah
[Music]
god just i swear to god jimmy i
swear to god i
swear did i i did the thing
i swear to god jimmy i swear to god
you are the most frustrating
thing i've ever dealt with
but it's fine because i'm just gonna i'm
gonna go to the ground floor because
i've made
such progress on this episode
that i'm gonna just get a little more
he is really a son of a [ __ ] there's
probably
like some nuance that i'm not capitaliz
i know i'm able to open that and yet i
do not have keys anymore
cause keys just vanish i don't know why
but keys say goodbye
oh i'm sweating i turn on the air
conditioner i'm sweating i can't handle
this
ah
i've got this weird tasting soda and jaw
huh such a difficult life
wait this way the hell are you pointing
at the hell are you pointing at
the hell are you pointing at what
the hell are you pointing it
what what are you looking at
the elevator
the evil leader no
what are you pointing at
the hell are you pointing at
i don't know that's so weird
it's definitely pointing down there but
there's nowhere else to go down there
so what do i do i'll scry i'll
i'll scry i literally
am i crazy there's there was nothing
other
oh radio god radio right the radio
maybe radio should i i don't know
probably should have radioed yeah
right cause of the whole burning fire
right right right right right right
right
right right right right okay wrap it up
wrap it up
wrap it up wrap it up okay
i wonder why jamie doesn't come down to
this floor
i don't know maybe he does okay okay
okay okay okay
okay so if talk hello
i can hear you there you are
there you are
yeah yeah it is harvey i saw you locking
jimmy in the basement
what happened kind of a dick move if you
ask me
[Music]
i wanted to give jimmy a dose of his own
medicine although he couldn't do any
damage down there
i was wrong
okay that definitely
is that connected to what you said about
the fire in the hotel
nobody realized how far to get attention
uh-huh attention attention attention
not i represent sure if that was a
tension but
definitely uh definitely got some wee
woos in the town going
okay okay okay harvey realized jimmy was
crazy
diddy now diddy now okay okay okay
so that's good now we just need to scry
one more time to know where wants to
send me
most likely the uh basement again but
i'm not 100
sure so we're gonna scry just to be
certain
just to be shortened and once we're
shortened we're good
we're good to go
we're good
i knew it my genius knows no
bounds my profound intellect
is stunning in every way actually always
that my
intellect is a huge an amorphous
blob of malign intelligence
that lives trapped inside my own skull
and then jimmy also i don't think is in
the basement
but also this is probably where i see
harvey die
however that's gonna be oh god
[Music]
harvey you down here uh the harvester
well it's pointing this way definitely
how about here
is it harvey
okay hello is here
is it javi harvey
okay the fire basement fire basement
[Music]
hotel
[Music]
fair enough fair enough uh but
is there anything that i could pair up
with this a gun
is this related does that have something
to do with what you've said about the
gun
i'd lost i
oh okay i thought maybe not but
uh okay apparently maybe yes
i'm getting i'm beginning to understand
that nobody's innocent in this
in this whole endeavor no one no one's
uh no one's not
guilty uh everyone seems to be a little
bit guilty but uh i'm guilty of running
out of time but somehow we managed to
make
progress stunningly i don't know how but
it happened
so thank you everybody so much for
watching get ready for more episodes of
this with a lot of progress when i learn
to handle jimmy properly
which is by grabbing him by both balls
and squeezing until he explodes so i'm
gonna look forward to that and you're
gonna look forward to that so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
you